hey everyone and welcome to my death
notes he's a breakdown now I know it's
easy to assume that every live-action
anime adaptation is going to suck but
what's important is that we keep an open
mind and our [ __ ] doesn't look good oh
god the [ __ ] starting already
oh it's getting worse no it sucks so
much it's just the first [ __ ] frame
and it's like so much larger they ruined
this alright what is this and who
decided to make life look like a cross
between male on and off this emo maguire
and max land is walking out to the
late-2000s panic at the disco album is
this what [ __ ] happens when someone
writes death notes in a Death Note now a
lot of people have been complaining that
there are cheerleaders here and I don't
see what the problem is I mean if this
was set in a high schools and they're
finally understanding the first steps of
properly adapting a [ __ ] anime alright
you see the scene here way too [ __ ]
basic obviously they've missed the
entire point of Death Note
but they're it's an easy fix so let me
do that for you there we go [ __ ]
perfect [ __ ] go well what is this if
they read an official Twitter account
for you some company actually pays money
for this to happen alright I don't care
what anyone says this is hilarious and
[ __ ] brilliant
without anything either properly not
felicity probe as we see here I want to
see tweets like this did you know
Shinigami love apples but not Granny
Smith those are for basic [ __ ] Pink
Ladies all the way Fuji's alright super
way too expensive
hashtag Tesco saw your selection out
mate speaking of or you can least we can
all agree that we you seems to be the
thing that's done right I mean I'm not
sure there's any concept shots of
emergency arms Jordi looks terrifying
they did an amazing job on Matt and I
can wake you up to this this is
houseguests on should always just
William Dafoe got bored again and ended
up starting another social purging by
giving this kid of Death Note why does
this happen every time I drink on a
Saturday night though hmm
not sure I've covered this in a nice
yeah wait here we go what is this dragon
notes
evolution to Last Airbender and the next
thing is alright yeah definitely or this
one hmm what the hell is up with this
play in whitewashing
why can't we just have a Death Note
filled with Japanese actors set in Japan
where they are speaking Japanese Light
Yagami more like light yagami
why are they speaking English in an
English adaptation this is rude and
offensive I'm disrespectful to the
Japanese culture good job gun cocking a
black elbow look if you're going to
Americanize it and change the Light
Yagami to like toner don't push you have
to do it half-heartedly if you're doing
this commit all the [ __ ] way yes God
reek nope I want to see death God Brian
justice for Kira please this is justice
for Kira's oh I think that's everything
I can say about what's been really wait
a minute
I've just been informed that we have
exclusive footage that's just been
leaked right now of one of the scenes of
the upcoming movie please be a whether
this could contain major spoilers to
Death Note and the upcoming movie so
watch this at your own peril roll clip
[Music]
okay serious talk time here let's just
all calm down for a second all right we
come we come good it's a 50,000 second
long teaser and that's way too little to
make any sort of judgments about the
overall quality of this thing where does
that be good or bad for all the negative
attitude surrounding this teaser the
only thing I've really had the problem
with it was indeed lights look and it's
not because he's white
it seems to replace lights for this kind
of edgy emo kid he looks like he would
have watched Death Note way back when
not starring it which goes against his
suave handsome poster child look his
character he's originally known for but
then again like it's supposed to be a
piece of [ __ ] of a guy and he definitely
looks like it so maybe that's what
they're going for L being black doesn't
bother me at all as long as you can keep
the quirkiness of the original character
having said that even then we don't know
much about how these characters are
being handled and how they fit into the
overall story of whatever they decide to
adapt there's very little context to
judge these so-called bad scene life
kissing someone well he also did so in
the anime as a means of manipulation
he's running and there are big set
pieces well honestly if they're able to
keep the psychological thriller aspect
and cat and mouse game absorbing who
really cares if there are some set
pieces one of the reasons the enemy
worked was because the animation and
direction was able to make much mundane
themes more dynamic and exciting which
is part of the reason why the
live-action version felt so [ __ ] flat
because it couldn't do that but even if
we're going down this route and judging
from some basic cinematography short
composition and design it sets a better
atmosphere tone and looks way better 70
than anything produced by the Japanese
live-action film there are competent
filmmakers behind this to the talented
horrid director so you don't have to be
so quick to jump from the hate bandwagon
and I mean William Dafoe is reuse
grade-a casting I just hope to get
reused looks look as terrifying as to
photos and no changing aspects like
names or location to fit a Western
adaptation is neither a sign that is bad
nor disrespectful and there is already a
Japanese adaptation so I'd be far more
disappointed if they just kept
everything the same with notes or we
understand that things need to be
changed for Western adaptations of
foreign film so why don't we put anime
up on this pedestal like it is
untouchable unchangeable work of gods
most of all though I am just tired of
the whitewashing debate and it
frustrates me that it looks like it's
going to become a [ __ ] trend that
whenever an anime gets an adaptation the
topic of racial casting will get more
attention than either the adaptation or
the original anime in question and I
have neither the patience nor the energy
to get in
this debate once again as I have already
done so but I will say if you're angry
about the casting choices at least keep
it consistent I've seen way more people
angry about life's being wipes and L
being black which is kind of
hypocritical look if this is really
about respecting the original Japanese
culture then either both are okay or
neither of them are if you want more in
depth reason as to why none of the
changes matter right now I've already
made a video why sometimes it's best if
an adaptation shouldn't stay faithful to
the original and also what about judging
an adaptation by its own [ __ ] merits
so can we all agree that whether this
film will be worth watching or not if
there is no potato chip scene we will
[ __ ] riot
[Music]